hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday January 11th 2016 what's going on
how are you how's it going I'm in a
great [ __ ] mood I don't know why you
know what I haven't boozed in like
[ __ ] I don't know what it's been out
nine ten days or something like that I
did have a sip of wine last night but I
don't really consider that boozing you
know the way I go after it is my way so
you know some was funny when I when I
stopped drinking my wife always tries to
get me back to drinking not to get drunk
or anything she just looks like you're
so [ __ ] you know I Drive her so
[ __ ] nuts that I just think sometimes
you know if she wasn't such a good
person I think she would try and like
drug me every night like around supper
right make a little dinner do that how
is that honey no look at you you look
sleepy like I have no idea like she just
put some [ __ ] my food not to like kill
me just to sort of sedate me
but anyways but I haven't drank in like
ten days or something wow that really
made my head go somewhere like wow it's
kind of [ __ ] up she does it buddy I
haven't drank in like ten days I uh I'm
feeling good and that's Oh what happens
is nice slowly you know I start to eat
better I'm starting my day off with the
old from the old country thing you know
you a little [ __ ] water at room
temperature which should make you gag if
you're any kind of a [ __ ] human being
but I get used to it with some lemon and
then a little cayenne pepper in it and
then I take let that settle with me then
I get a couple scoops of Greek yogurt
the all-natural stuff that actually kind
of tastes like sour cream and the first
time I ate it I was like this is the
worst [ __ ] I've ever tasted because I
was used to the the crack baby yogurt
that I've been eating my whole life that
has like [ __ ] 40 bags of sugar in it
you know and yogurt you're like yeah I
mean Piemonte of sugar that's been
[ __ ] regular yogurt your money you
should [ __ ] snort
I mean it's literally like I mean I'm
not gladdie I still [ __ ] love it but
uh the Greek [ __ ] took me a minute and
now I'm actually I like it man I drink
this [ __ ] and just have a couple scoops
of that it kind of fills me up and
that's kind of the big thing is you
become an old [ __ ] like me it's just
just somehow getting the hunger to go
away without doing damage to yourself
you know and then walking around and
burn in a few calories before you go to
the next one you know and I know this
bunch you know hopefully some younger
listeners listening to this judging
meiko's there's old fart talking about
[ __ ] lemon water cayenne pepper and
[ __ ] Greek yogurt well you know
something if you're lucky enough you'll
live long enough we don't [ __ ] up
something or something bad doesn't
happen to you yeah you know to get to my
age and you know it's good to start
healthy habits now let's shut up Hill
what are you the [ __ ] first lady you
know what I'm doing right I'm doing [ __ ]
they're like a first lady does right now
I'm actually let's get in shape kid how
about you go outside for 10 minutes a
day and you just do some jumping jacks
can you [ __ ] believe that they got to
tell kids to go out and play you know
that's how [ __ ] insane video games
have got I mean if I made video games
and I actually saw Michelle Obama on TV
begging kids to try to not have their
first cardiac incident by the time they
were in the third grade I mean I would
tear up and just be like I did it you
know I am so [ __ ] great at my job
I've made children
stop playing outside you know if you
click there's like at the Alec Baldwin
of the video game industry you know from
Glengarry Glen Ross coming in just
screaming at him yeah me kids I caught
to have a heart attack seven [ __ ] no
right just screaming at him trying to
get him to we haven't done our [ __ ]
jobs till every kid has a [ __ ]
pacemaker by the step is great
I don't know anyway so yes so I'm trying
to get back in shape so I've been stoned
sober so yesterday I got my my first
massage and like I don't know like two
years whenever I get a massage
afterwards I always think like I got to
start doing this man this is great for
an old fart like me you know and then
you come home you crush the waters you
get all the toxins out of here whatever
yoga [ __ ] they tell you to do and but I
know this always has them I don't
[ __ ] do this you know what once once
your month I'm gonna go down there you
know [ __ ] you haven't workout my
[ __ ] back like my hole where I don't
know what's like I have a little
curvature of the spine and the lady's
like where the problem areas right and
of course your brain always goes my dick
but you know it's a legal place I think
we have any problem in the central
pelvic area on the frontal lobe I'm like
my I never even noticed that either I
was like my right shoulder my right
forearm and my right foot and I was just
like wow how [ __ ] up is my right side
and then I realized all of them all of
those injuries I got from playing drums
you know my right forearm from [ __ ]
holding the stick wrong I don't know
what I'm doing with my shoulders
probably after I [ __ ] up another fill
looking at the bait sprayer and
shrugging like I'm sorry I mean I tried
to get back on one right and then my
foot I [ __ ] that up years ago trying
to get my bass drum as fast as John
Bonham's you know which I never even
remotely achieved I just have the
lifetime pain you know every time I take
a step I'm always reminded of what a
wonderful drummer John Bonham is so
anyways I did that with the lovely Nia
that's always a good thing to do you
know you go in there with your wife then
you don't feel like a dirt bag because
anytime I go to get a massage I always
feel like a dirtbag there's just no way
not to feel like a [ __ ] complete
piece of [ __ ] when you walk in there
yeah hey don't you want you to work out
the kinks this we had you know to be oh
wait a minute what am I talking about
I got a massage in [ __ ] nuh muwah
no I didn't know I did now that was a
steam that was a steam that's right oh
that's right that's right
yeah I guess I had on like two [ __ ]
years and they always do the same thing
when they when they put that my hands on
my back they just go wow wow do you have
a lot of stress has it been a while like
is your back feels like gravel so
anyways we did that and then we came
home and we made a Mario Batali's
lasagna Bolognese and was [ __ ]
delicious homemade pasta homemade pasta
things and all that I got to get my
homemade pasta game up I try to make the
spinach pasta and mr. pasta was
definitely green but he could still see
the chunks of spinach in there you know
I mean so what does that mean did I not
knead the dough enough was because it
was frozen spinach like it said to be
like the the recipe said to be am I
saying that right like the recipe said
said to be what the [ __ ] does that mean
like the recipe said it should be I
think that's what I was trying to say
but um you know when I dried it out and
maybe I just didn't dice it up enough I
have no idea but um I'm actually psyched
at a the consistency though I can get
that down I might have needed it needed
to knead it a little bit more I don't
know
is there any higher qualified people out
there that could help me out on how to
make the right spinach pasta because I
watched some videos and I still [ __ ] the
thing up but anyway so we did all of
that and meanwhile I was watching like
the playoff games playoff and [ __ ]
great games this weekend Heartbreakers
but just [ __ ] just great games what's
also that that creeping sadness that I
always have when the playoffs are here
that it's just like did another regular
season go by that [ __ ] fast
god dammit it's going to be over is
another month it's going to be [ __ ]
over this time next month is goodness
I'm not going to say cause it's going to
be too [ __ ]
pressing however I have gotten totally
into the Celtics and NBA hoop with my
Bruin so I mean I got a game almost
every night sometimes too but anyways so
let's go through them let's go through
them is every [ __ ] douche who doesn't
like sports is going to roll their eyes
just fast-forward like [ __ ] 40
minutes and you'll be safe the first one
I saw I think I want I taped all of them
so I watched them at weird times I
watched the second half of the original
text and the Kansas City Chiefs just
absolutely dominating the the new Texans
and I actually tweeted that out on
Twitter I actually got a ton of [ __ ] for
it people like oh what are you trying to
show up your sports knowledge it's like
now I like share in it I love when
people do stuff like that I'm a sports
nerd okay I'm not acting like I played
at a professional level I just love that
[ __ ] so I'm going to take you through it
for those who didn't know that the
Chiefs are originally called the Texans
they actually played in Dallas Texas
when the AFL first started and when the
AFL first came out the NFL the
established league publicly laughed at
them and said these guys are crazy then
this will never work hahaha whatever I
you know I now are not nervous at all
we're just going to do you know the
American people know where the quality
football is that right that's what they
said publicly and then behind the teams
as much as they may or may have not
believed that they then hedge their bets
and they wanted to try to sabotage the
AFL as much as they could before it even
got started
so the AFL how many [ __ ] teams did
they had they had the Boston Patriots
the Buffalo Bills the New York Titans
the Dallas Texans the Minnesota Vikings
and I'll get back to that before you say
that I'm wrong on that they had the
Minnesota Vikings ice know this by heart
Denver Broncos Oakland Raiders San Diego
Chargers I'm sorry the Los Angeles
chargers
and dolphins weren't in it Bengals
weren't in it the [ __ ] else is left
bears Lions yeah something like that I
probably forgot a team or two and so the
owner with the most money was Lamar
Lundy I believe that was his name I
didn't look the [ __ ] up again I've read
this whole book on it Lamar Lundy and he
was the wealthiest of all owners so
basically this guy could hold out the
longest in this new crazy venture all
right so babe well how they attack the
[ __ ] AFL they did it on two different
levels the Dallas Texans were owned by
Lamar Lundy the most wealthiest of all
the owners so what they the NFL did was
they awarded Dallas a team which became
the Dallas Cowboys so for a season or
two I forget I didn't look it up as I
said that you could either go see the
Dallas Cowboys or the Dallas Texans now
the Dallas Cowboys as much as they were
an expansion franchise you could go down
and watch them get the [ __ ] kicked out
of them you know by Johnny Unitas Jim
Brown or you know Frank Gifford well
these guys you know all these legends
the [ __ ] Green Bay Packers would come
to town you get to see Vince Lombardi
and of the the early days of the Packers
sweep you could see all this
professional level Talent or you could
go across town and go see the Dallas
Texans a bunch of nobodies playing a
bunch of nobodies because they want to
establish yet so obviously that
completely that's a no-brainer as a
sports fan you're going to go see the
NFL team and go see all these stars that
you've been watching on TV so that
completely [ __ ] them and they had to
move to Kansas City and they became the
Chiefs they kept their colors though but
they were originally called the Texans
but they gave up the name and then the
Minnesota Vikings which I did not know I
didn't know any of this [ __ ] till I read
the book the Minnesota Vikings were
originally going to be an AFL team so
what the NFL did was not only award
Dallas the team they also went to the
owners of the Minnesota Vikings and said
hey do you want to just join the NFL and
not be part of the AFL come on we're an
established league and of course they
said hey [ __ ] you guys and your new
venture
we're going to [ __ ] [ __ ] the whole
going against the NFL we're going to
join them so that's what they did they
they opened a franchise across town from
the wealthiest owner and then they stole
one of their teams that that was their
two moves as they publicly laughed at
the ASL so there you go there's a little
[ __ ] little little history from all
freckles but having said that you know
maybe they got him back but I guess
they'd have to beat the [ __ ] Cowboys
and they're also part of the NFL so
congratulations to the Chiefs and
evidently they're playing the Patriots
is what I got from some of the tweets
and I am not a comfortable Patriot fan
no Patriots fan who's been watching the
Patriots is you know we had a lot of
losses towards the end of the year I'm
hoping you know we're going to get some
help back on our offensive line or
either way it's going to be even if we
were healthy it would have been a brutal
day because you know Andy Reid is no
slouch as much as the guy gets a ton of
[ __ ] I mean the guy's been to a bunch of
NFC championship games and [ __ ] like
that he has been there before but you
know you do need the players you do need
the ownership you need all of that type
of [ __ ] to try to uh to try to succeed
so congratulations to them and I'm by no
means comfortable with next week and and
you know also you know the Chiefs beat
the Seattle Seahawks as far as being the
loudest fans at one point and they did
it in that old a stadium rather than the
stadium the Seahawks fans have that
helps them out and contains the sub such
a good but it's true
and yeah so speaking of the Vikings and
the Bengals my condolences to fans of
both teams I've been there
fortunately have not been there in a
long time I guess the Giants losses but
I can't whine as a fan with all the
other [ __ ] that was going on but uh
Jesus [ __ ] Christ what the [ __ ] was
that guy doing after he picked off the
ball walking up to the tunnel already
celebrating I thought [ __ ] athletes
were superstitious the [ __ ] are you
doing
right there yeah right I it's [ __ ]
unbelievable to me
and then he's [ __ ] sitting there he
probably already took his goddamn cleats
off and then the very next play whatever
the two plays in they fumbled the
[ __ ] ball I had to watch this part of
the game on highlights where they taped
the game for the one time I don't do the
extended [ __ ] record this [ __ ]
happens and probably to put his cleats
on run back out on the field and he was
so [ __ ] frustrated because he still
had champagne you know coursing through
his veins
he was already mentally the next week
that he goes into was the same guy right
goes in and [ __ ] knocks out that
player I'm [ __ ] believable I'm
[ __ ] believable hey steel offense how
many you shut the game off after the
interception huh not because you're a
fair-weather fan just because you
couldn't stomach to watch the Bengal
fans jumping up and down and having some
joy you know I I forgive you if you did
that I'd forgive you if you walked away
you know or if you already started
celebrating and you turned your big
[ __ ] sausage eating back to the
[ __ ] TV and you're already doing wet
day but up but up who do we got next
week do it all that [ __ ] [ __ ] brutal
and the Vikings I won't even I don't
even can you explain to me how you
placekicker had the laces facing your
kicker twice in one [ __ ] game and a
playoff game that sounds [ __ ] I've
never seen you never see the laces in
right I never even knew about I'm not
gonna lie to you I didn't never even
knew about laces out Spence [ __ ] Ace
Ventura that's when I learned about it
or is it a spand Tura um change this
[ __ ] I mean I watched the replay of that
game and I went on Twitter beforehand
and I found out that Vikings won what
you [ __ ] sucked but I was in the
middle of you know trying to make
spinach pasta which was well beyond my
cooking abilities so you know I was a
little [ __ ] not got a little sideways
there for a minute and I was thinking
like what the [ __ ] happened he must make
this field goal and then Seattle just
has a ridiculous kick
off return and then they're able to kick
it or maybe they score a touchdown or
maybe a defensive back falls down I had
no idea that he was going to [ __ ]
lose it oh my god [ __ ] brutal but you
know what every championship team you
got to have a little bit of luck first
[ __ ] Super Bowl the Patriots won we
had the Tuck rule which was a [ __ ]
rule that everybody blamed
Tom Brady it was a blame the officials
or not the rule rules committee for
coming up with that weird one because I
say to this day that's a [ __ ] fumble
that's a fumble the way sugarbear
Hamilton did not interfere with Kent
State the year the [ __ ] Raiders won
in Super Bowl 11 so anybody in Oakland
put your [ __ ] hankies away because I
don't hear you crying about it that was
payback for Super Bowl of the not super
11 the [ __ ] playoffs playoffs in 77
when Shiva Bear Hamilton was already in
the air jumping at Ken Stabler and then
he lets the ball go and they called
roughing the passer and back then it
wasn't a 15-yard penalty oh it they put
the ball where the guy threw it and it
was the end of the game he threw 50
yards [ __ ] prayer ray Hamilton's
already in the [ __ ] air lands on Ken
Stabler they call roughing the passer
and they took the ball from like the 50
and put it on the [ __ ] one-inch line
and then the Raiders went and won the
[ __ ] game so I don't want to hear
anything about it but I am man enough to
say that the Tuck rule was [ __ ]
horseshit and uh I think it's a fumble
you know but I'm not expecting that
level of maturity from Raider fans you
know a fan base that goes to the game
you know dressed with you know spikes on
your shoulder pads that have been
checked by security to make sure that
they're totally safe as you make a I'm
not safe angry face
you know something that does bug me I
can't stand when they [ __ ] when
people get upset that Hollywood has the
audacity have awards to have award shows
and they always talk about these self
congratulatory night like what business
doesn't have an award show it's just not
[ __ ] tell
you know if you [ __ ] drill for oil
you know they have the best of you know
BP and all them may have their [ __ ]
yearly [ __ ] Christmas party you know
best regional manager goes to Clem Clem
field out of [ __ ] Mishawaka Clem I'm
paying for that cause girls tonight
Katniss's wife here you know they do and
they give him a little [ __ ] trophy
they have salesman of the month [ __ ] you
work at McDonald's you can get employee
of the month you know you know they have
franchise of you you join the [ __ ]
Cub Scouts you tie your [ __ ] shoes
they give you a little badge to sew on
your [ __ ] shirt right why isn't
Hollywood allowed to have their little
[ __ ] evening what is it huh what is
it that bugs you if there's a bunch of
hot famous ass there Jesus I'm sorry you
know what I want to Elmo see somebody go
out there and defend Bill Cosby on an
award show dead serious and just [ __ ]
hold it and never let anybody in on the
joke and then try to continue hosting
and do it in the monologue let's see if
they ask you back alright I'm done being
a [ __ ] Pat's first Kansas City but I'm
not this is what I want to [ __ ] read
here I want to read the live reads
advertising alright Dollar Shave Club
everyone Dollar Shave Club lots of
players will be sporting playoff beards
now that oh now that the post seasons
here leave that to the pros kick off
your year right with a fresh blade
that's why a millions of others have
joined dollarshaveclub.com - I know the
key to getting the amazing shave what
the key to getting amazing shave is
simple one use a fresh Dollar Shave Club
blade to use that dr. cabbies easy shame
but that's it
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing
razors right to my door for a third of
the price of those greedy mega razor
corporations that
means listeners who switch now can
afford the luxury of Shaving with a
fresh blade anytime and save hundreds
this year and when you combine that
fresh blade with the adductor cabbies
easy shave but it just glides
it's unimaginably smooth I'm telling you
it's not your average shave foam and it
won't dry out your skin which is great
the all natural ingredients leave your
skin feeling soft smooth and moisturize
even after the shape take it from me use
a fresh Dollar Shave Club blade with dr.
Carver easy easy shaped butter one time
added to do if you want the most gentle
shave imaginable
join the dollarshaveclub.com slash per
revolution today that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash / alright blue
apron alright you need to know how to
cook not only well I mean if you want to
be healthy you need to know how to cook
all right
Jesus bleep and you're coming right out
with the generalities not only do you
feel like you know your way around the
kitchen but cooking at home means eating
healthier and saving money instead of
ordering expensive takeout again but
where do you start blue apron has you
covered for less than $10 per meal blue
apron delivers all the fresh ingredients
you need to create home-cooked meals
just follow the easy step-by-step
instructions each meal can be prepared
in 40 minutes or less
no more overwhelming overwhelming trips
to the grocery store no more sad takeout
plus you know what's great is if you
know you're dating some chick and she
doesn't know you know you're dating some
guy whatever the [ __ ] you doing and they
don't know that you don't know [ __ ] in
the kitchen you know you whip this
[ __ ] thing together they look at
maybe somebody I could be with you know
you looking for a relationship but maybe
somebody they could each meal can be
prepared in 40 minutes - left no
overwhelming trips to the grocery store
no more sad takeout sorry read that no
matter your dietary preferences blue
apron makes it a breeze to discover and
prepare dishes like blah blah blah blah
blah right now in your kitchen cook with
ingredients cook with ingredients that
you've never used before like watermelon
radishes I've never heard of that farro
farro Farr oh and purple potatoes and
recipes between 500 and 700 calories
proportion delicious and good for you do
this if you're [ __ ] working out
trying to get shape this is [ __ ]
perfect right now you can get your first
two meals for free at blue apron calm /
/ that's blue AFRICOM / / hi blue apron
calm / / blue apron a better way to cook
you know it'd be great even if even if
you you know have a nine-to-five regular
job
you start off with a decent breakfast
you bring you [ __ ] lunch and then you
order blue apron at night and y'all know
it they say y'all y'all you all know
what I'm talking about
dinner it's what [ __ ] your diet at
least for me because I can eat well the
whole [ __ ] day a whole day I'm doing
good I'm doing good and then by [ __ ]
4 o'clock I'm like a like a gypsy like
an ice-cream you know you can just
[ __ ] call these [ __ ] and have them
deliver a 500-700 meal and you just
[ __ ] eat the [ __ ] right and then
you're done drink water to the rest of
the night have a little celery already
cut up you know throw in full of peanut
butter in there you know it's going to
melt off unless you have you know I know
some built an excuse you know like a lot
of overweight people do oh my metabolism
is really slow yeah yeah that 8,000
calories a [ __ ] day dude alright MV
MT watches oh you know we only have four
this week so I don't I do - and - let's
do that alright let's get back to the
thing here alright uh today as I'm
rushing through this [ __ ] podcast I'm
having somebody coming over looking at
my garage today I even have to whisper
this [ __ ] I somehow talked my wife into
you know allowing me to have just have
somebody come over and take a look at
the garage I know I did that a couple
months back but then I got busy but now
I got the person coming back again and
I'm actually using her skills you know
that she does with me that's how I ended
up with a dog like we're not getting
this dog we're just were fostering the
dog for a couple days because she knew
that I'd fall in love with the [ __ ]
dog and then that would be it so it's
kind of like when you first start to
start dating a woman you know when she
wants a relationship when she comes over
the apartment
she starts to do is she leave [ __ ] there
because it gives an excuse to come back
man's [ __ ] nuts right like they're
thinking that far ahead
oh you're sitting there's a good look a
little good Slugger right that's all
you're thinking and they're sitting
there plotting you know what I mean it's
like you're some [ __ ] head coach that
has no game plan and she's across the
field like [ __ ] Bill Walsh calling
the first twenty five plays of the game
right oh I love a football life there's
a nice reference to use so you know it's
[ __ ] hilarious and speaking with
Patricia O'Neill benefits coming up once
again tell you Chris Patrice story he
was so [ __ ] brilliant that I remember
he was dating this woman and you know or
whatever seeing her and she started
leaving [ __ ] around his house and I just
had brought that up okay yeah you know I
dated swim you know she left this [ __ ]
here and she left that like what the
[ __ ] you know I only see you like you
know once every two weeks he just has
[ __ ] there so for two weeks I keep
looking at her [ __ ] brush of the
shampoo she left though or whatever and
it's just I keep thinking about her and
it's annoying me and Patrice just goes
he goes so throw it out I go what it
goes throw it out I don't you throw it a
brush he goes I would look at the [ __ ]
out he goes yeah he goes I did that they
told me a story but there was a woman he
quit messing around with and she left
these toiletries and a little bag of
like you know makeup and brushing all
that and he he [ __ ] threw it out and
then he came back like a week and a half
later and she goes to go in the bathroom
she's like she took hey what did you do
with my my stuff he goes and he just
plays dumb he goes what stuff she goes I
left shampoo here a little makeup bag
because I was young I saw it out and she
was like literally beside herself but
actually on some level respected him so
like [ __ ] realizing what she was
doing
and also I think because that early on
he clearly let her know in a very funny
[ __ ] way that he wasn't looking for a
relationship and nah but she was able to
relax and kind of be thinking at you I
was just [ __ ] alright I wanted a
little more he doesn't at least but he
let her know so [ __ ] early on that it
didn't really hurt you know that make
sense I mean I maybe I'm speaking for
her but hey I guess I am but whatever
either way it was [ __ ] funny no Jesus
was that the [ __ ] worst
I literally just jumped out of the plane
and pulled the [ __ ] ripcord on that
story sorry it's been a while it's been
a while since I told that story resident
why have I told it before I don't
[ __ ] know so anyways so I'm kind of
using my the same [ __ ] tricks that my
wife used that got me the dog I'm using
with her because we're gonna like hey
why am i whispering here like she can't
just listen to the [ __ ] podcast
[ __ ] society dude sometimes like how
dumb I am it just really [ __ ] so
anyways what I want to do is I have this
old-school [ __ ] you know my house was
built in 1923 so the garage whenever it
was [ __ ] built was built to house
like a [ __ ] Model T Ford kind of car
and those things for those things you
set inside the [ __ ] wheel wells you
know what I mean if you look at old cars
you know how the fenders used to flare
out and then there was just the engine
and you know you sat like literally like
right behind basically what you you sat
me I can't I don't know if I'm
explaining correctly you know what I
mean you sitting inside the [ __ ]
wheel wheel well so I'm not like
literally in them but as far as like the
line down the side of the car right like
if you stuck your head out and you
didn't have any fenders on it you'd be
looking at the [ __ ] tire right as
opposed to you know the [ __ ] Road I
know all you guys know I'm talking about
it also goes to show you I like how
[ __ ] fat and big people have gotten
you know I mean two things if you ever
go to Mount Vernon
at Thomas Jefferson's house and you have
to duck underneath the [ __ ] the the
[ __ ] you come the doorframes
you see how much taller people are and
then when you look at those old [ __ ]
cars the fact that two adults could sit
side-by-side like that and it would be
probably not even touching each other
you know so many ways what I'm trying to
say is that my my garage is long and
skinny and it's like high up you know
and and then it kind of flares out at
the back as it kind of wraps around the
back of the house a little bit so what I
want to do the front part is long enough
for me to squeeze my truck in there but
then in the back what I want to do is I
want to turn that into like a little gym
which my wife is all for and then I'm
also pitching that I build the maybe a
little drum room I could actually I got
this drum kit that I bought that I have
in cases that if I want to play it I
have to throw in the truck and drive it
down to a studio I'm thinking of making
building like a room within a room which
will add no value to the house too
unless I someday to sell it to another
[ __ ] drummer who also whispers on his
own [ __ ] podcast like his wife can't
hear it [ __ ] I'm still whispering but
you know I you know what because the
guys coming in like a half-hour and my
wife is asleep downstairs and she hears
me yelling about it I might have to have
this argument sooner than I'm prepared
to have it so that is the game plan
and like a couple months back I bought
those atomic holds you know all those
things like those that American ninja
[ __ ] still down downstairs in the garage
I want to just have those hanging from
the ceiling so I can do all that grip
strength [ __ ] that I want to get better
at by the way I [ __ ] started working
out for the first time in forever and I
went to do clothes do pull-ups holy [ __ ]
I live expelled like as like glass
sandbags in my pockets what the [ __ ]
going on I did six good ones and
whimpered through the last four I always
try to do ten I can't even [ __ ] and do
it's pathetic so that's like the big
exciting thing in my life right now and
I got to kind of get this thing going
before my wife wakes up and
to find something else to do in the
house
you know maybe I don't know so anyways
by the way people I'm doing a gig in our
Vancouver I'm doing a gig in Vancouver
Canada this Sunday night a last second
one that was added because I left my
January open because I'm still waiting
to hear about a season two we meet with
Netflix this week to pitch them our
ideas for season two so if you've
already watched efforts for family I
thank you so much because you've got me
to at least getting the meeting so we'll
see we will see what happens with that
and so I hadn't booked anything in
January so now we're having some
last-second gigs coming up I'm going to
do a gig in Vancouver this Sunday and
then I'm going to do a couple dates one
or two dates I think right before the
Patrice O'Neal benefit in the tri-state
area we're still trying to [ __ ] iron
those things out as we speak Jesus
Christ Oh spit it out all right let's
get to the the questions of this week
all right
inbox inbox inbox where's the content
here's the con no I had it on the other
page am i doing now there we all right
bill Patriots first Kansas City hello
there mr. burr how's it going your
freckled country how are you I hope your
holidays were just peachy same to Cleo
and Mia today I just wanted to hear your
honest and objective thoughts about the
matchup between your past and my Chiefs
this weekend I was just listening to
your podcast from 12:00 7:15 well you
said Casey won't win [ __ ] somebody
tweeted me that I said that I talked so
much trash I don't even remember saying
that and I'm content that you may eat
those words this week oh absolutely
oh I absolutely might eat those words
this week but having said I think I
meant what Casey won't wind [ __ ] he's
not going to win the Super Bowl that's
what I mean my pick is the Seattle
Seahawks which is not really a is not
really a genius picked by any stretch of
the means they've been that to [ __ ]
years in a row I mean didn't they win
yesterday without Marshawn Lynch I was
running back and forth trying to make
lasagna noodles as far as I know I
didn't see Marshawn Lynch in there
my wife was also clicking back and forth
to like the [ __ ] Golden Globes so I
just know that they know when I'll wait
that was that was the earlier one dude
you know yesterday I watched I watched
[ __ ] Ohio State Indiana I watched two
playoff football games and I watched
half of a Celtic game and fell asleep
was [ __ ] ridiculous so I'm trying to
remember what the [ __ ] I saw this
weekend but um no I don't think it's
going to be an easy listen I got to tell
you this if we were [ __ ] healthy we
would kick the [ __ ] out of you all right
if we actually had an offensive line and
Edelman was back and Amendola was back
we had a [ __ ] running game and we if
we were healthy this is no [ __ ]
contest at home you know it and I know
it right now Brady is driving a [ __ ]
rental car so you might go in there and
beat us and then you're going to get all
[ __ ] excited and loud and you know
what I don't know you know why would I
rule against you guys hey you know what
you guys hey you guys haven't won since
what 1970 alright what was that uh what
was that [ __ ] Hank Stram call power
trap cross 57 times height rise what the
[ __ ] is that thing called I don't
remember you guys have enough when you
beat the [ __ ] Vikings Jesus Christ
going way back you beat the AFL team
that [ __ ] sold out maybe that's why
they're cursed
maybe that's why they've lost what do
they lose three three four Super Bowls
three Super Bowls all right they lost to
the [ __ ] chief they lost to the
package they lost to the Dolphins and
they lost to the Steelers is that right
wait the Dolphins lost to the Cowboys
then they beat the Viking
they beat the Redskins that's right she
beat the Vikings green baby
the Chiefs they didn't beat the Raiders
did they they beat the Vikings right now
the Vikings would have been in the NFL
by then I don't [ __ ] whatever you
want like [ __ ] three of them maybe
cuz you didn't stick with the AFL guys
does that make any sense
whatever good luck to the Chiefs this
week good luck to the Patriots obviously
my heart is with the Patriots but uh you
know I don't know I didn't like that
Dolphins game or every time Brady the
few times he went back to pass there was
if somebody right in his grill every
[ __ ] time
but whatever the end of the [ __ ] day
we have the greatest [ __ ] quarterback
and coach of all [ __ ] time so go [ __ ]
yourself I think we're going to beat you
alright
it'd be no fun if I just said good luck
to you guys so [ __ ] you guys you don't
stand a chance there now if you beat me
you got something to talk about then you
can trash me and I can fill out a [ __ ]
hour next week on the podcast all right
drive to school oh by the way I dreaming
Alabama Clemson I have no I don't know
[ __ ] about either team I was so [ __ ]
busy in the fall I didn't get to watch
anything but of course I wouldn't care
if Alabama one but Clemson hasn't won in
a while so I'd love to see them win
however if Alabama wins it just makes
the Cleveland Browns futility even
funnier to me because the dumbest
[ __ ] move ever do you realize that
they had Bill Belichick and Nick Saban
coaching their team and they fired them
the bust of [ __ ] Paul Brown Vince
Lombardi of the modern-day NFL and the
Paul Brown Bear Bryant Vince Lombardi of
NCAA division one football they had them
both coaching together and they fired
so Alabama is a Cleveland Brown fan you
have to be rooting
for Clemson you just have to you guys
have had enough [ __ ] pain right
who knows maybe LeBron can get you over
the hump this year you know I always
root for clean like I said I have
relatives you know family that grew up
out there and all the type of [ __ ] I
actually love Cleveland so however I
also love a good joke so if Alabama wins
tonight it'll still be funny anyways
continue on drive to school hey Bill
I've been a fan of yours since the oh
and eight days and Chappelle show
somewhere along the line I had a kid and
he's old enough to listen to some of
your podcast I listened to it with him
on the drive to school I listened to the
whole episode before beforehand and cut
out any of the stuff that is a bit heavy
or sexual Jesus you're [ __ ] great dad
when you start editing their content you
know look at you you're a regular
typical not because I'm sheltering him
but because he and I don't need don't
need share certain podcast moments when
you talk of jizz and up in some skank
before 8 a.m.
exactly let the kid have a childhood
trying to keep it light and positive
with the exception of the funny negative
anyways I wanted to tell you that it's
the best thing we got going we listened
to about 15 minutes a day it puts him
and I in a laughing mood which he needs
schools a lot of work these days and he
always got a ton of homework and project
and is dragon in the morning
this wakes them up sometimes we pause
and talk about certain things that I'll
explain certain stuff them about
politics sports etc in other words
corrected dumb [ __ ] that I said all that
father-son stuff thanks for the parental
assist that's great who would ever
thought my ignorance could be hot
warming
anyways I'm already regretting [ __ ]
making funny Ricky Gervais what did I do
that [ __ ] but you know I mean he's
making fun everybody on the show it's
only fair right they showing up with
[ __ ] acceptance speeches and he's got
all those [ __ ] zingers at him and his
writing staff wrote it's only fair
that's why I like Mel Gibson Mel Gibson
gave him [ __ ] back I understand why
people just go out smiling they should
[ __ ] trash prespective me
dear bill I don't want to get a
vasectomy I just don't my wife and
anyone else who chimes in on the subject
started trying to break down positives
and point out the lack of negatives
never just not want something I just
don't want one can you believe this or
you with everyone else that it must be
rooted in some fear etc [ __ ] back dude
[ __ ] that are you [ __ ] kidding me
do you think you could [ __ ] tell a
woman what the [ __ ] to do with her body
for two seconds before she just said
you're a you're a chauvinistic [ __ ]
yeah dude [ __ ] that [ __ ] that all day
long that's your [ __ ] dick and balls
all right that's what they [ __ ] with
your dick if you don't [ __ ] want them
to go in there snip snip whatever the
[ __ ] I've even looked up the operation I
still don't get it I don't get it
nothing comes out so does it stop your
ability to make chiz do they put a
Nutter down there well you got to milk
the jizz out of that's disgusting I I
don't get I don't get what happens but
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that just just
sit down GYC listen I don't want to do
that and she'll be like why why not you
just you just fear-based it's like no
isn't I don't want to be walking around
and like dude you know what that's like
you're like a muscle car and they want
to rip the engine out and put a [ __ ]
v6 in there [ __ ] you and keep you a
Shelby badge on the side of your car and
every day in the morning you wake up
standing in looking at yourself after
you got out of the shower knowing that
it's a life [ __ ] that dude [ __ ] you keep
the bullet to that gun all right she
can't handle it you know
you know what is she going to do to you
huh she going to hold you down and make
well someone else does it just yeah you
don't want one dude you don't want one
to the level you're reaching out to a
[ __ ] podcast okay do you understand
now would even use that me your argument
just be like but don't play this audio
though
that's allergist they listen I so do not
want to do this that I actually wrote
into a podcast to get advice that's how
much I don't want to do this and then
she'll just be like well maybe we need
to go talk to somebody about it which
means she's going to set up an
appointment with somebody who agrees
with her all right because she's going
to set up the appointment con listen my
husband needs to get a vasectomy he's
very nervous he says he doesn't want to
get it but it's going to be the best for
us and she's going to totally set the
[ __ ] table
it's like those dumb [ __ ] that go on
dr. Phil you ever see those sad sacks
that go on that [ __ ] show with their
wife like they have a [ __ ] prayer dr.
Phil's audience does women so he's going
to have to side with the woman every
[ __ ] time even if you know he's going
to try it out you know hide his hand and
give her a little bit of [ __ ] but at the
end of the day he's going to be looking
to you go you need to get your ball
snipped right he's going to come at you
like that
while he sits there you know with his
junk still [ __ ] working you know he's
got a giant [ __ ] unit doesn't he do
that big [ __ ] goof that big bull goof
walking down the hall and you know he's
got a [ __ ] giant [ __ ] unit big
great Great Dane balls I don't know why
I think he's got a [ __ ] giant unit he
does he's just like he's just herb
butter the way he talks he just God
always gives them big dicks it just I
don't know what it is this giant size 16
brown wooden wingtips just sitting
across from you there's got to be the
worst [ __ ] show ever to be on oh my
god I never thought about dr. Phil's
junk before you see that it takes
somebody to [ __ ] bring up a vasectomy
you'll never be able to think about them
again laying in my big dick say you need
to listen to your wife alright jumping
out of a plane hey Bill where are you at
on jumping out of a plane
if you're a [ __ ] American I'm a
Brit how much money would it take you to
jump I got a bet with my mate that you
hate Heights and it takes 500 thousand
US dollars
don't change your answer to be contrary
to what I just guessed keep it fair good
sir thanks Jesus another arrogant Briton
these guys think they're [ __ ]
geniuses I've already done it you
[ __ ] idiot and I paid someone to do
it I paid I went to in Pepperell
Massachusetts when I was 19 years old
and I didn't do a tandem jump either I
did a static line jump I've told this
story on the podcast sir if you're a
little bit more up on it and also I have
a pilot's license I fly helicopters so
if I was afraid of heights I mean I'm
afraid of heights look if I don't have a
parachute on my back and I'm not in a in
a vehicle that's designed to fly then
yes I'm afraid of heights like I don't
like you know like if you like at one
time I watched a YouTube video and they
just showed these guys that had to climb
up to the top of this [ __ ] building
and then not climb through a little bit
they took the elevator was kidding hope
they were they were on the roof and it
was already on the [ __ ] roof this
building was so [ __ ] high up and you
know the wind up there must be
ridiculous I would literally just lay
down in the fetal position and crawl
back to the [ __ ] door that leads to
the stairwell reach up to the handle and
[ __ ] go back down but this disc dude
then climbs the [ __ ] the the whatever
though the radio tower or whatever and
it just keeps getting higher and higher
and higher in the tower gets smaller and
smaller and smaller and he's hooking and
unhooking his safety line I literally
I couldn't mean obviously the guy lives
because it's his GoPro on his helmet and
I've never been so [ __ ] unsettled
watching something in my life okay then
I would hate Heights but I think at that
point everybody hates Heights but yeah
when I was 19 years old I went to this
place in Pepperell Massachusetts which I
don't think exists anymore there might
still be an airport there and they had a
school and I did the static line jump if
you've ever seen that movie
Fandango one of Kevin Costner's earlier
ones where to do from Breakfast Club
Judd Nelson his character jumps out
that's exactly what I did and I remember
when we went up the command was sit in
the door get out and then he slapped you
on the shoulder and said go and I
remember when he said sit in the door I
thought he was saying close the door so
I was reaching up I'm sitting down
reaching up trying to close the door he
had this big smile on his face like he
thought I was chickening out I feel like
I just told this story on the podcast
and then I find really who's saying sit
in the door so you sit in the door and
basically it's one of those planes where
the wing is above the aircraft you know
it's on top of the aircraft as opposed
to below which actually gives you much
better sight I would think as far as if
you wanted to look down and then there's
the support that goes to the side of the
plane so and then right above one of the
landing wheels the wheels don't retract
on this plane they had welded a little
step so you sat the [ __ ] door and I
forget how high we were at want to say
we were only like 1500 we weren't that
high up because your chute immediately
comes out
she said you sit in the door then he
goes get out and then what you do is you
reach out and you grab that support beam
from the wing and you hold on to that
while one of your feet is is standing on
that little step thing and then
basically what you do is
acting this out so I can remember is you
then basically you you bend your arms
and you bring your chest like flush with
the support beam and then the foot that
dangling you put it straight out behind
you it's almost like a yoga pose so we
fit in the door get out and then he
slaps your shoulder and he goes go and
you let go and then you you arch you arc
right arc one our one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand look if
nothing look reach pull and when you're
looking you're looking over your
shoulder to see if your shoot came out
and then if nothing you look down at the
handle so reach pull it because for some
reason they say if you don't look down
you might be flailing because you're
panicking cause it's the first time you
jumped in the shoot didn't come up sorry
cayenne pepper ah hang on a second
so anyways I get out he goes go I let go
and instead of arching I I don't know
what I did I just reached for something
all I know is I started doing front
front flips as my shoot was coming out
and I felt it go by my leg the inside of
my leg I felt it go by my leg I felt
something hit that and I was immediately
thinking oh my god I'm gonna roll right
up in this [ __ ] thing like you know
when you put bacon on shrimp and the
second I had that thought like the shoot
already had come out and by the grace of
God I didn't get tangled up I think
about that sometimes like how easily I
could have [ __ ] died and then boom
your shoot comes out and when your shoot
comes out you don't even feel like
you're falling because there's nothing
going past you because you're above the
tree line and all that so you just feel
like you just sort of suspended in the
air and there was a radio and this lady
just talked to you in she say pull the
left toggle and you had to pull it all
the way down to unique because I
remember there was just this big girl on
the class and she couldn't get it around
her hips and she landed across the
street in a pile of Lou
and not dislocated her knee I remember
that before and then I went up after her
and I was just like [ __ ] and then they
have this ridiculous you know when you
get to the tree line you suddenly
realize how fast you're falling I think
it was like 17 feet per second or maybe
11 feet I can't remember but it was
really fast it was like basically you
know jumping off of a basketball rim
like how fast you come down it had to be
a little bit slower right no no because
you're not reaching terminal velocity I
don't [ __ ] know so all I know is when
you hit the ground what you're supposed
to do is look straight ahead because for
some reason if you look down at your
feet what you were going to do they were
worried you pick your feet up too
quickly and somehow break your legs so
what you had to do is look straight
ahead and as right as you hit the ground
you're supposed to do this little
[ __ ] like collapse down and then this
big ridiculous bring it both your legs
straight up in the air and then over to
your side I don't know why I doubt that
they still have people do that and I did
what everybody else did is I came down
and the second my feet hit the ground I
did a faceplant right into the grass and
my buddy grabbed the the mic from the
person and called me a [ __ ]
something like that what a [ __ ] or
something in the in the in the radio so
yeah there you go so I did it and what
are you basing [ __ ] American on
huh
are you tough guys over there with your
fish and chips have you done it yet 500
you I there's nothing you keep something
if I don't want to do something I
wouldn't do it there's not money that
you can give me I know he goes oh it
broke a break now I'm making great money
I got enough money I got enough money
I'm good to take my life in my [ __ ]
hand now that's one of those things now
now I was back working at the warehouse
I mean granted I paid somebody when I
was working in a [ __ ] warehouse I
[ __ ] you know let's see how much would
be I mean if they gave me literally if
you gave me $400 you would have doubled
my pay for the week so I would have done
that
let's see let's go back to the building
to climb up that building how much money
would they have to give me when I was
working in the warehouse
eight hundred dollars and that now for
that debt building uh I would say yeah I
just wouldn't do it
I'm all right I'm all set I'm all set I
you know I should actually send you guys
that video so it's not that I hate
Heights err
I hate risking my life to that level if
there's like a parachute or something
like that
it is a bungee cord or there's like a
[ __ ] safety line that's fine but
really going up that tower where I have
to unhook the safety line and then hook
it back up and there's wind and [ __ ]
[ __ ] that that's too much of a risk I
wouldn't do that but uh you know what I
was [ __ ] sorry College cooking dear
Billy Boyardee oh that's a great one
what a great one Billy Billy Boyardee
I'll [ __ ] I got to wrap this up this
guy's coming in 12 minutes I'm sure
everyone is blowing you up to make
another cooking video so don't worry
this isn't that I'm a college student I
know you've lived like a college student
in India early 30s from past stories
about living with Bobby Kelly off till
we weren't living like college students
we were live in like [ __ ] animals do
you have any menu suggestions besides
pasta what would you mix together I'm
pretty creative and I do alright but I'm
open to some suggestions what's good to
throw together on a budget not a flaw
you know what dude I would go to now but
this is what I would do I would go on
YouTube and I would ask that question
and you'll find videos and then just
start searching and at some point you're
going to connect with somebody and I
feel like I'm you know dropping the ball
here on the question but like I'm not a
chef I'm not even a cook I'm really
early on this too this myself so that's
what I would do this
bunch of old episodes of Mario Mario
Batali's moto Mario mo LTO mario i
really suggest watching those just watch
the guy i used to just watch the show
and just by watching it you learn things
and you start to see how things are made
and and the big thing is not having you
just have to learn [ __ ] in life you got
to have the the mindset of like I'm you
know I'm going to [ __ ] this up probably
the first time and that's alright and
then I'll get a little better like the
pasta already just even just running it
through the pasta maker I already have
like three or three [ __ ] things that
I'm not going to do the next time and by
the way somebody gave me a great tip on
you after you've on kneaded the dough
and you put it through your pasta maker
be sure to to doused like both sides
with flour be liberal with the flour
because if you don't it's going to tear
it could tear when you're Nick because
it's supposed to be like sticky and
elastic at the same time and when you
run it through there yeah you could you
could possibly have some issues and it
tears and that's a big [ __ ] pain in
the ass and then he gets sad you feel
like a [ __ ] failure and you're not he
had the balls to try it so I would I go
that Rachel Ray's got a great bunch of
great ones from back in the day but he
always makes fun of her but she would I
need 20 minute meals he has a little
[ __ ] laugh she'd do ice to watch your
[ __ ] all the time
that's great [ __ ] for probably where
you're at but I would also Google some
stuff like that but it's great as a
college student if you start to learn
how to cook if you start to learn how to
cook right now and you do it religiously
you are going to be a [ __ ] beast
compared to the average person but it's
by the time you're in your 30s to forget
it if you add like [ __ ] like learning
how to how to make a pie crust because
then you can make turkey pot pie you can
make quiche you can make all of this
[ __ ] you start making homemade pasta
forget it it's [ __ ] over then you
learn how to do all this other stuff I
forget what I mean I made it with me I
was really concentrating on making the
pasta she did the Bolognese and then she
did the whole milk
costing but I just was watching her do
that well you heated up some butter and
some flour and then you heated up some
milk then you poured the whole thing
together instead of using like ricotta
cheese or any of that type of [ __ ] you
use this really rich milk thing was
almost too much the [ __ ] dish was
like it almost tasted like a dessert it
was so [ __ ] good but I didn't know
how to do [ __ ] when I was your age so I
think it's great that you're doing it
you know you want how about blue apron
sign up for that [ __ ] and just you know
steal some of their meal ideas and then
expand on them if there's an offensive
style of cooking that they give you then
you go on YouTube and you just start
looking at recipes about that like you
know what I don't know anything about
which is weird because I love the food
is any sort of Asian style cooking I
actually smoked some ribs and I and I
had this uh.this dipping sauce that was
like a you know whatever Chinese a
Japanese influence you know with the
[ __ ] soy sauce and all that and it
was I was in a part of the grocery store
that I never went to and it was the [ __ ]
it tasted great and that's something I
was kind of thinking this year I want to
get down pasta and and start to have
some Asian type dishes in there so if
there's anybody out there that can help
me with that I'd appreciate it so
anyways the guys coming here in eight
minutes I got to upload this [ __ ] I'll
talk to you later